Speaker 1: There have been some outtakes released
from this stunning interview that Kanye West did
with Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson
that are so insane and so anti-Semitic that
they raise a whole new series of questions about
Kanye's seeming obsession with the Jews or Jew,
as he sometimes refers to them. This is
super interesting. So over the last week,
there's been a lot happening with musical
artist Kanye West, wherein he showed up in
Europe with a White Lives Matter shirt, and then
he appeared with Tucker Carlson and talked about
how great Trump is. And it was like really
a very kind of fawning interview. Of course,
because Kanye West has become useful to
the right. And then he ended up getting
suspended from multiple social media platforms
for basically just going on an anti-Semitic tirade
and attacking Jews and saying, I think Diddy is
controlled by Jews and all this different stuff.
Vice's motherboard, that's the source
for these clips has now uncovered.
Clips from the Tucker Carlson interview that
were cut from what was broadcast. And they are
absolutely and utterly insane. And we're going
to look at a couple of these. And what I want to
mention to people is. I think my audience mostly
knows I'm Jewish. I have had experiences with
antisemites of every flavor casual anti-Semites
who just unthinkingly have attach themselves to
the very easy tropes. You know, Oh, Jews are
cheap. That's one I dealt with with other
employees when I worked at Circuit City. I've
recently tweeted about that. There's also the sort
of more conspiratorial people about an elitist
cabal Bilderberg, Rothschild, you know, this sort
of stuff. Then there's also the black Israelites,
which we're going to get into in a moment. There's
all sorts of these different flavors, and some
people are just obsessed with the Jews. They
look at Jews as the sole cause of everything
that is bad on our planet. Okay, let's get
into the first clip in. This is an outtake. Okay.
Kanye says that the founder of Planned Parenthood
created Planned Parenthood with the KKK to control
the Jew population. And again, this one, you
could say this one is not overtly anti-Semitic,
but it's all part of the obsession with Jews.
Check this out. Let's go to the first one.
Speaker 6: Planned Parenthood was made by
Margaret Sanger, a known eugenics with the KKK
to control the Jew population. When I say Jew,
I mean the 12 lost tribes of Judah. The blood of
Christ. Who won the race? The people known as the
Race Black really are. This is who our people are.
Speaker 1: Yeah, this is. This is super
confusing. So try to follow along.
Speaker 6: The blood of Christ. This,
as a Christian, is my belief. And I believe
that if we saw ourselves as more. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So. Well, first of all, Margaret
Sanger, early sort of women's rights and
family planning advocate, was Jewish as far as
my research reveals. So the idea that she wanted
to control the Jew population, I don't really
know what Connie means. Control it by lowering
it or boosting it. I don't know. This is all
completely bonkers. Now, when Connie talks about.
The race. Black are the real Jews. I know some
in my audience already know about this and some
don't. There is a movement called the Black
Israelites or the Hebrew Israelites. It is
a movement that goes back to the late 1800s,
where some mostly Pentecostal black Christians
started to claim that in a revelation,
they learned they were the true Hebrews.
You can find examples of the term Hebrews,
Israelites, the real Jews, whatever.
Generally speaking, this is a pretty racist
movement in the modern day. They claim that
Jews are sort of devilish imposters and
that the real Jews are black folks. Okay.
Let's let's leave it there. There was another
clip in which Kanye used a weird metaphor
and then brings up the Jews again in the
metaphor and then asks for it to be cut
from the interview to which you'll notice
Tucker Carlson says, Done. When Kanye says,
I want that cut out. Tucker says, Done. This
also is interesting because it exposes that
more than likely part of the agreement for this
interview was Kanye has sort of like final edit
and can ask for anything to be cut. How common
that is on Tucker Carlson's show? I don't know.
I've never given that to anybody on our program.
Speaker 6: Exactly what our culture is based on.
Think about us judging each other on
how white we could talk or be, like,
you know, a Jewish person judging another
Jewish person on how good they danced
or something. I mean, that's probably like a bad
example where people going to get mad at that. But
another thing that they do that I probably want to
edit that out everybody, and I'd like that done.
Speaker 1: Tucker says. Consider it done, Kanye,
you're producing here.
Speaker 6: Okay. So,
you know, I was talking to Ice Cube
today and we got really beat up in
2020 for saying we need to approach things a
different way and not just be trauma drunk.
Right. Which is a term that you got. Okay.
Speaker 1: So again, the example he tries to
go to is something about Jews obsessed with
Jews, realizes it's going nowhere and then
asks for it to be cut out. Small note here.
Kanye did say during the interview that he's
vaccinated. That was cut out from the final
cut that aired. I don't think that was Kanye's
request. That seems to be a Fox News decision.
Speaker 6: No. Every day we've been killing each
other in the streets every day. One of our amazing
things with Mayor Suarez is the murder rate has
gone down. And I don't I mean, you said that
question up. You have more information about the
about the about what happened in the hospitals.
So in all honesty, I don't have the most facts.
There's many facts. I mean, in your life. Like so
I'm at a COVID vaccine being stuck inside. Like,
what did you think of all that? I was I was
vaccinated. It was interesting, a friend of mine.
Speaker 1: So I was vaccinated, was removed
from the final cut. And then lastly here,
just again, the continued obsession with
Jewish people. And in this one, he does the
sort of sort of like money trope where he says
he would rather his kids know about Hanukkah
rather than Kwanzaa because it'll come with some
financial engineering. And again, this is the idea
that Jews control the financial system, and this
is one of the oldest anti-Semitic claims around
and Kanye is full in on it. Listen to this.
Listen how casually he mentions this, too.
Speaker 6: Biting my tongue on my political
opinion because I thought it would be better
for my children. And now you look up and my kids
are going to a school that teaches black kids a
complicated Kwanzaa. I prefer my kids new Hanukkah
than Kwanzaa. At least it will come with some
financial engineering. Kwanzaa doesn't, you know.
Speaker 1: And so and by the way, I could tell
you at Hanukkah, nobody talks to you about IRAs
or a compounding interest. It's just not it's
not where I ever learned about that stuff.
He's obsessed with Jewish people. And I have
seen people like this. There are folks who get
fixated on particular things. And sometimes it's,
you know, the hammer that turns everything into a
nail for them is Jews. Sometimes it's, you know,
the Trilateral Commission, sometimes it's
geoengineering or control through fluoride in the
water system or whatever the case may be. Fox News
has sort of backed off with a number of segments
in the last 24 hours saying the interview,
the White Lives Matter thing is interesting,
but all the tweet, the anti-Semitic tweets, that's
too far. Maria BARTIROMO, for example, and others
and they're talking this up
to mental illness. And again,
sure, mental illness can be a factor, but most
mentally ill people don't become obsessed with
the Jews. Really bonkers stuff from Kanye
and I find it all to be completely horrible.